what do you think about Twitter what do
you think about all the
fun activity happening recently since uh
Elon yeah bought Twitter
I think you should make me CEO like I
tweeted
well I should say sort of we had with
just like a couple hours ago had a
conversation with Elon and uh you guys
had an exchange of some excellent ideas
so yeah I I legitimately think obviously
you're exceptionally busy but I
legitimately think it would be awesome
if you somehow participate in the future
of Twitter yeah it would be fun because
there's so much possibility of different
ideas first in the sort of the uh the
content like dissemination hosting and
all the different recommendations like
the search and Discovery all the things
that YouTube does well I think the most
exciting thing is he's you know willing
to move fast and so I think there's
going to be a lot of interesting things
that come out of it because he's just
moving quick and a lot of these more
mature platforms just take years to do
the simplest stuff and they're very
bureaucratic and
um so it's gonna I mean it'll be
interesting to see which way it goes
when you just kind of take a move quick
break things whatever type approach to
social media I'm actually pretty curious
to see what features he rolls out so
what will be your first uh act as
Twitter CEO
I can't spoil it okay I gotta get hired
what do you think about video on the
platform yeah do you think that's an
interesting or is it like messing with
the the medium the nature of the
platform I think Twitter will always be
closer to tick tock than it is to
YouTube I gotta at least in this current
form like I don't I don't see 20 minute
one hour long videos or whatever you
know even 15 minute videos being watched
over there I see it more as like the
short and snappy stuff closer to tick
tock
but at the same time Twitter is a really
good comment section for the internet I
mean it's almost weird why like why
doesn't Twitter allow you to embed
YouTube videos like why why does some
you should just ask Elon that like I
don't know if that's a YouTube thing but
when uh YouTuber posts a video why do
they have to link to YouTube why can't
they just embed it on Twitter and just
play it there I mean wouldn't that just
solve a lot of problems yeah but then
the two companies that have to agree to
integrate each other's content I don't
know but it seems like a win-win I mean
well it's more of a win for Twitter
because then people don't have to leave
the platform I mean that would be the
the easiest but who gets like when you
watch the ads on a YouTube video that's
embedded in Twitter who gets the money
it would still be YouTube but at least
then right now people just post a link
and it takes you off Twitter and it just
kills your session time on Twitter
that's really interesting but that yeah
because the Twitter whatever the the
Dynamics of the comments especially once
the spam Bots are taken care of Twitter
just works it's really so Reddit is a
nice comment section for the Internet
it's like slower Pace more deliberate
like a higher effort Twitter's like this
High paced like ephemeral kind of stream
but there's the vote the upvoting the
downvoting works much better because you
can do retweeting right because the
social network is much stronger than it
is on YouTube like the interconnect
activity yeah on Reddit you're gonna get
the the top replies are going to be the
most refined ones whereas Twitter stuff
floats to the top that's not super fun
but like you're saying it's more off the
cuff stream of Consciousness which a lot
of people prefer it's a little more
personal
how do you think Twitter compares to
YouTube in terms of how you see its
future unroll in 2023. I mean I think
YouTube's gonna be YouTube and not much
is really going to change but it's going
to keep growing just because you know
that's just what it does and because
it's owned by Google
um but Twitter I don't know I mean it's
one of those things like you you can't
predict if I you know a year from now an
economy is going to be in a recession or
booming and I think Twitter's kind of
the same thing one thing's for certain a
lot of things are going to be rolled out
but who knows honestly you responded to
Elon saying Twitter's unlikely to be
able to pay creators more money than
YouTube
um what do you think that is well yeah
because I I think the tweet I responded
to is one where he was saying
um that they you know users will jump
over if Twitter could potentially pay
more than other platforms and I was just
saying obviously because Google has
Google AdWords and I mean that's
Google's whole thing it's putting ads on
stuff they've been doing it better than
anywhere else in the world for a very
long time it's very unlikely in the next
few years that Twitter is going to
magically or any platform you know give
a Creator the ability to make higher
cpms than on YouTube uh it's it's kind
of crazy like some creators in in
December you know Q4 because ad rates
are higher because of Christmas and
everything some creators literally make
like 30 40 per thousand views and that's
after YouTube's cut like it's almost
like hard to think about like how high
the RPMs get and even then once you pull
out a financing cars the highest CFM
niches and you move into just normal
stuff it's still just crazy the sheer
volume of creators and the fact that all
of them get these multi-dollar cpms at
Scales it's pretty beautiful